sallie Challen is still adapting to her
free life not only is she out of prison
but for the first time she's free to
decide how she lives mental abuse is the
most difficult thing to explain to
people I think that over the years mine
was like a drip feed coming at me and it
came to a crescendo at the end it's
something that makes you question your
own mind
we should did rape me he did drag me
down the stairs and throw me out of his
flat once you don't know how to get out
of it because you're so conditioned to
being with that person you can't see a
life without them sally met her husband
Richard when she was just 15
they married had two sons and were
together 40 years the outside world a
happy family what people didn't see was
that sally was a victim of sustained
psychological abuse a crime now
recognized as coercive control and in
August 2010 after suspecting Richard
have yet another affair she snapped I
gave him his food and I said to him am I
going to see you tomorrow and he said
don't question me don't question me and
I grabbed a hammer that was in my bag
and hit him they say I hit him 18 times
I can't think that I could possibly have
been capable of doing something
something he just snapped inside me I
admit that the hammer was in my bag but
I've got no recollection of putting it
in there
I then covered him up and wrote a note
saying I love you um I put it on his
body I went home and then the next day I
went to beat she head where I was
planning to jump and it was only the
police negotiator who talked me through
everything and mentioned about how my
sons would be on their own which made me
come back from behind
the fence do you regret what you did oh
god yes I wish I could turn the clock
back he didn't deserve to die and I'm
really sorry for what happened Sally was
sentenced to life for killing Richard a
trial she barely remembers by the time
my trial had come up I dropped
considerably mentally and it was just a
blur all I can really remember is being
asked questions and answering I suppose
so
I suppose so I think the main thing that
I remember is my eldest son screaming at
my sentence I thought I'd die in prison
I didn't think there was any hope but
hope came when coercive control was made
a crime while sally was behind bars it
allowed her lawyers to fight to change
her case to manslaughter ultimately
leading to her release it was surreal
really walking out of there but I want
to help those that are still there who
shouldn't be there they need a voice and
I think I have to be that voice for them
Sally wants to use her story to educate
others about coercive control and
highlight the importance of a proposed
new law on domestic violence it has to
happen otherwise you can have the
situation where you have more women in
prison for killing they're pushed to the
brink and it's the only way they can see
that they can get out it was right that
I went to prison but i reaiiy think the
charge and the conviction was wrong now
that I say that I've come out the other
side I want to help other people fight
for justice
Charlotte Lomas Sky News